de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
de la fórmula de cambio de base del
logaritmo y está lo que nos dice es que
si tenemos un logaritmo base a de x que
eso es igual a el logaritmo base de de x
entre el logaritmo base b de a para
cualquier base del logaritmo que se nos
ocurra y este es un resultado muy útil
para muchísimas cosas pero bueno una de
las cosas para las que es útil es por
ejemplo si tu calculadora solo puede
calcular logaritmos base de 10 o
logaritmos base y necesitas calcular por
ejemplo el logaritmo base 3 de 25
entonces esta fórmula te da la forma
para calcularlo y bueno lo primero que
tienes que hacer es si tu calculadora
puede calcular logaritmo base de 10 y
logaritmo base pues escoges alguno de
los dos entonces con él me dicen escogen
el 10 o l
ok bueno vamos a empezar con el 10
y creo que es el único que vamos a hacer
pero el 10 es suficiente porque es para
cualquier base de entonces logaritmo
base 3 de 25 según esta fórmula es igual
a logaritmo base de 10 de 25 entre
logaritmo a base 10 de 3 y ahora si con
esto la calculadora ya nos puede decir
cuánto vale esto
bueno ya que vimos una de las cosas para
las que esta fórmula es útil pues vamos
a probarla no vamos a empezar por el
logaritmo base a de x llamarle ya para
que la demostración sea mucho más
sencilla ok entonces tenemos que es
igual
logaritmo base de x ahora qué es lo que
significa que el logaritmo base de x sea
igual ayer pues ustedes que ya conocen
todas las propiedades del logaritmo me
van a decir muy rápidamente que esto lo
que significa es que a a la ye es igual
a y bueno resulta que voy a necesitar
este espacio por lo cual voy a poner la
x hasta por acá entonces tenemos esta
igualdad que sale de esta igualdad pero
entonces definimos la variable y como
logaritmo base a de x y eso tal cual lo
que significa es que ha elevado a la i
es igual a equis y dada esta igualdad lo
que vamos a hacer es sacar el logaritmo
base de los dos lados entonces logaritmo
base de d
tiene que ser igual a logaritmo base b
de equis
y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
recordar todas esas propiedades del
logaritmo y bueno ustedes díganme esto
que es igual como podemos simplificar
esta expresión
en algún vídeo donde explicamos las
propiedades del logaritmo vimos que si
estamos evaluando el logaritmo en una
expresión que está elevada a alguna
potencia entonces la potencia podría
salir del logaritmo
o sea lo que vimos es que esto es igual
a g por el logaritmo base de d
si pueden consultar la igualdad de aquí
para acá en algún otro de los vídeos que
están en la página de khan academy
entonces este es exactamente igual a
este que a su vez es igual a este
entonces podemos bajar esta igualdad y
ahora pues miren ya tenemos bastantes
cosas no o sea tenemos logaritmo base de
de x que está aquí logaritmo base de a
que es justo lo que queremos aquí y ya
que es el logaritmo base de x o sea lo
único que necesitamos hacer es despejar
la ok y para hacer eso lo único que
tenemos que hacer es dividir de los dos
lados entre el logaritmo base b de a y
dejamos la ye solita
y entonces como estamos dividiendo entre
los dos lados de la igualdad por la
misma expresión entonces el preservar la
igualdad y ahora fíjate que aquí
logaritmo base de a entre el logaritmo
base de a pues todo esto
en realidad es un 1 esto es igual a esto
es igual
por uno pero a su vez ya es igual a el
logaritmo base a de x
entonces acabamos de terminar de
demostrar la fórmula de cambio de base
del logaritmo que iba a ser muy útil
para cuando queramos calcular las
derivadas por ejemplo